the cold war was a hotbed for innovation
and technological development that gave
us incredible planes like the sr-71 and
fairchild republic a-10 warthog
but it also gave us some of the worst
planes to ever get past the drawing
board the cold war gave rise to several
bizarre aircraft like avro canada's take
on the modern day ufo northrop's tactic
blue stealth aircraft which looked like
it was designed by a three-year-old or
the peculiar thunderceptor with its
booster rocket motors which was obsolete
before it even hit the runway but
perhaps the worst of all was the
relatively normal looking
xf-84 thunderscreech
while it looked normal it did not sound
normal the thunderscreech was so loud
that it often made its ground crew
physically ill so loud that the power of
the sound waves emanating from the plane
were capable of knocking people over and
on one occasion caused an engineer
working on a plane nearby to suffer a
seizure
the insane noise this plane created is
what gave the thunderscreech its
infamous name and to this day holds the
world record for the loudest aircraft
ever made
today we're going to learn why this
abomination was created
sharing what the plane sounded like here
is practically impossible recordings
give us this fairly standard sounding
droning noise
[Music]
it's impossible to emulate over digital
audio because the thunderscreech ungodly
noise was caused by shockwaves being
thrown outwards by the strange propeller
design the thunderscreech was a unique
plane born out of a unique need during
the early development years of the jet
engine the navy needed aircraft with
short takeoff runs so they could take
off from aircraft carrier runways to
give them a competitive advantage near
enemy territory
this required something called climb
performance which jets at the time were
not particularly good at
the propeller planes of world war ii
were superior the propeller design
allows these aircraft to take off from
aircraft carriers with much shorter
runways and climb faster however when
competing with other more powerful jet
aircraft speed was the obvious limiting
factor that higher maximum power allow
jet engines to go fast really fast and
when building an interceptor aircraft
speed is important republic designed
this abomination in an attempt to get
the best of both worlds great climb rate
and great top speed the thunderscreech
was a supersonic propeller design a
propeller designed to spin faster and
achieve much higher top speed than a
conventional propeller creating a
propeller capable of providing the
thrust needed at these higher speeds is
not easy the velocity of air around a
propeller blade travelling at constant
rotational speed increases steadily from
the root of the blade to the tip at the
tip of the blade air will be leaving the
propeller disc at a much faster speed
than at the root of the blade even
though the rotational velocity is the
same for all parts of the propeller the
tip of the blade travels a much further
distance than the point near the root of
the propeller and therefore the linear
velocity is much higher at the tip as
the propeller tips approach the speed of
sound air becomes highly compressible
and large pressure differences result in
bubbles of unstable air and shock waves
around the propeller tips
the disturbed air results in an increase
in drag and a reduction in propeller
efficiency and could lead to other
complications like propeller stall
keeping the propeller efficiency as high
as possible at the expected operating
speeds is thus an important criterion in
propeller design
the propeller efficiency can be thought
of as the ratio of power in the form of
thrust produced by the propeller to the
power actually produced by the engine
this graph shows the typical propeller
efficiency profile for a fixed pitched
world war ii aircraft relative to speed
we can see that the propeller efficiency
rapidly plummets at higher speeds as air
becomes more unstable over the propeller
propellers spinning at supersonic speeds
with this kind of efficiency curve are
untenable if propeller planes were to
compete with jets engineers needed a way
to prevent this drop-off in efficiency
for this reason the supersonic propeller
of the thunderscreech was much shorter
in length effectively delaying the
shockwave formation for as long as
possible by reducing the circumference
the tip needs to travel during a single
rotation this reduces the tip velocity a
propeller with half the radius will have
half the tip velocity even if it is
spinning at the same angular velocity
however this alone is not enough to
prevent efficiency issues of a
supersonic propeller the propeller of
the thunderscreech after all was
rotating at supersonic speeds even when
on the runway the next big difference
between conventional propellers and
supersonic propellers is the angle at
which the blade is placed relative to
the air striking it supersonic
propellers are fitted with a much larger
angle to the axis of rotation relative
to conventional propellers and
critically the thunderscreech had a
variable pitch propeller meaning the
propeller can change its angle of attack
at different speeds to optimize
efficiency to understand this let's look
at a normal aerofoil cross-section when
it travels forward it will provide lift
perpendicular to the cord line if the
aerofoil increases its angle of attack
which is the angle between the direction
of movement and the chord line the lift
and drag of the aerofoil will change in
magnitude we can map this with the lift
to drag ratio which is essentially our
efficiency curve for an aerofoil we can
see that the wing generates the most
lift for the least drag penalty at an
angle of attack of two to four degrees
a propeller is essentially an aerofoil
but its free body diagram is a little
more complicated because not only is the
propeller aerofoil moving forward
relative to the plane's direction of
movement but it is also rotating around
the axis of the drive shaft let's name
these two separate velocities propeller
velocity is the speed of the propeller
rotation and plane velocity will be the
forward velocity of the plane these two
velocities combine into a new vector
called blade path
this blade path angle is not at the same
angle as the angle of attack of the
propeller blade
but critically the blade path is the
actual angle of attack of air traveling
over the propeller to understand this
let's see what happens to a fixed
propeller when we increase our propeller
velocity right now we are looking at the
optimum angle of attack of around 3
degrees
but if we increase the propeller
velocity the angle of attack begins to
increase reducing the propeller
efficiency
the same happens if we lower the
propeller velocity both move us away
from the optimum angle of attack we can
set the rotational speed but remember we
said that the propeller velocity changes
along the length of the propeller with
the tip having much higher speeds than
the roos that means if the propeller was
just one fixed angle of attack only one
section of the propeller would be at the
optimum angle of attack
so the propeller blade twists along its
length to ensure each part is working
efficiently
but the forward movement of the plane
also affects this angle of attack
four early planes whose top speed did
not get that high having a fixed pitch
propeller didn't matter that much
the forward movement of the plane only
marginally affected the angle of attack
on the propeller
but as speeds increased variable pitch
propellers began to become commonplace
allowing propellers to rotate and adjust
to higher speeds and maintain the
optimum angle this was essential for the
thunderscreech and you can see it has a
very large range of rotation for its
short propellers to ensure it can
operate at the large range of speeds it
was expected to encounter the blade
profile of supersonic aerofoils are
different from normal propellers too
research into this began in world war ii
as the engines were getting continually
more powerful the prospect of propellers
operating in transonic and supersonic
ranges was becoming more and more likely
with little to no empirical data
available researchers were forced to
build specialized wind tunnels and
measurement technologies to research how
different propellers would operate they
tested swept back tips after data
obtained from germany showed its merit
but manufacturing difficulties and
marginal improvements discredited the
idea
the engineers after much trial and error
landed on making the propeller blades as
thin as possible tapering from a
thickness ratio of five percent at the
base to just two percent at the tip
that is the ratio of the aerofoil depth
divided by its width the propeller was
also to have sharp leading edges with
little to no camber when tested these
propellers were capable of maintaining
their efficiency much higher and over a
wider range of speeds
however even with the propeller
efficiency improved the drag associated
with the formation of shock waves over
the entire propeller demanded an
obscenely powerful engine the
thunderscreech had an engine horsepower
of a whopping
5850 nearly four times more than a
typical supermarine spitfire
the engine installed in the
thunderscreech was unusual the engine
was actually two engines connected
together to power a common drive shaft
this is called a coupled engine if a
suitably powerful engine is not
available it's often easier to just
couple two engines to reach the total
power needed rather than developing a
completely new engine the practice does
have some other advantages too the
coupled t40a1 engines of the
thunderscreech were placed inside the
fuselage typically uncoupled engines are
wing mounted which creates a lot of
additional drag which is avoided when
the engines are placed inside the
fuselage wing mounted engines also come
with some control issues in the event of
an engine failure if one engine stops
working our working engine creates
asymmetric thrust which will cause the
plane to yaw in the direction of the
faulty engine with two coupled engines
driving a single propeller our thrust
remains on the center line just at half
power
finally coupled engines have some fuel
consumption advantages
turbine engines typically reach their
highest efficiency at higher power
settings but military planes often
operate well below their highest thrust
setting this graph plots the specific
fuel consumption versus horsepower for a
single engine we can see that at 3 400
horsepower the engine has a lower
specific fuel consumption than at half
power of 1700 meaning it is operating
more efficiently one of the advantages
of coupled engines is that each engine
can run the propeller independently so
if we wanted to run at half power we
could just turn off one of the engines
and run one of the coupled engines at
the more efficient peak power of 3400
whereas if we have two separate engines
mounted on the wings because of that
asymmetric thrust issue we would have to
run each at a less efficient half power
setting increasing fuel consumption and
decreasing range and loiter time the
powerful coupled engines did come with
some added complexity that caused a lot
of issues the engine was mounted behind
the pilot with air intakes placed in the
root of the wings this wouldn't be weird
for a modern-day jet engine which
derives its thrust from a nozzle at the
rear of the aircraft the thunderscreech
had to somehow transfer power from the
back of the plane to the front and it
did this with two drive shafts running
on either side of the pilot which is a
bit terrifying considering these drive
shafts were turning at 14
300 revolutions per minute and caused
the plane to violently vibrate
this rpm had to be reduced before
reaching the propeller so the
driveshafts fed into a 6.8 to 1
two-stage reduction gear to bring the
propeller rpm down to 2 100 revolutions
per minute much slower but that speed
still caused some serious issues for
control
when the propeller spins clockwise it
creates an opposite reaction force that
could cause the actual plane body to
spin anti-clockwise with the extremely
high rotation speeds of this propeller
this effect was particularly pronounced
and became even worse as the plane
picked up speed according to hank baird
a test pilot who flew 12 flights with
the thunderscreech it became a handful
when you got it out around 400 knots the
propeller governor would start surging
and the airplane would roll rather
violently the entire airplane in fact
was trying to torque itself around the
prop shaft rotating left while the prop
spun to the right the propeller governor
is the mechanical device designed to
sense the speed of the propeller and
control its pitch
at a particular speed it seems that the
sheer inertia of the heavy fast spinning
propeller overloaded the control system
and caused it to malfunction
causing the propeller to increase in
speed and cause even more torqueing
motion of the aircraft
this torque effect was present at all
speeds of course
and the designers of the thunderscreech
were well aware of the problem this
affected many propeller fighters of
world war ii it affected the rotary
engines of world war one even more
rotary engines rotated around a fixed
crankshaft meaning the entire engine
rotated with the propeller which helped
tremendously with cooling and helped
bring down the weight of the engine for
these underpowered aircraft but the
gyroscopic precession was so strong that
the sopwith camel had to use left rudder
for both left and right turns
the torque effect is usually most
prominent at lower speeds where the air
travelling over the plane has less power
to resist the rolling motion without
counteraction the torque could roll the
thunderscreech up to 30 degrees off
centerline
using the ailerons to counteract role is
possible but that introduces adverse yaw
where the increased drag caused by the
actuated aileron causes the plane to yaw
so the designers of the thunderscreech
included this anti-torque vein just
behind the cockpit on takeoff and
landings the vein was deflected 45
degrees which caused a counteracting
lift that acted around the rolling axis
of the plane another unique feature of
the thunder screech is its t-tail
configuration which particularly stands
out because it required a modification
from the f-84f thunder streak jet
fighter which the thunderscreech was
based on
this was done to get the stabilizer out
of the way of the prop wash and the
turbulence associated with it which
could reduce authority of the stabilizer
during pitch
the plane was still a serious handful to
handle leading to one hilarious quote
from lynne hendricks to jim rust
republic's chief engineer you aren't big
enough and there aren't enough of you to
get me in that thing again
test pilots are a unique breed of crazy
yet this one knew this plane was not
safe to fly 10 out of 11 flights for
hank baird ended in an emergency landing
the engine was so unreliable the plane
flew with its ram air turbine constantly
deployed just as a precaution the
turbine could use ram air to power the
plane's electronics if the engines
failed
between this the plane violently
vibrating from the two drive shafts
spinning at 14 000 rpm on both sides of
the pilot the sudden rolling due to the
propeller surges and of course the
immense sound that was capable of
knocking people over the plane never got
past the testing phase the program was
soon cancelled
weird experimental projects like this
are often the only way we can learn new
things
just trying something new outside of
what we already know
that was our goal when we started our
nebula world war ii series the logistics
of d-day where we developed new
animation styles that have permeated
into what we do here on youtube and for
the past year we've been playing around
with new animation techniques for our
next series and those blender animations
you have been enjoying on this show are
a direct result of that experimentation
our new series will deep dive into all
of the nitty gritty tactics from
engineering to logistics that helped the
british win the battle of britain the
first episode is now nearly complete and
we are hoping to begin releasing
episodes in the new year nebula gives us
a place to experiment in safety without
any worry of alienating our current
audience on youtube or being demonetized
for covering sensitive topics like war
your support there has helped this
channel evolve and grow
and we are able to give you exclusive
content like this as our thanks
many of you will be happy to hear we
have finally released a roku app for
nebula giving you even more options on
how to enjoy our videos ad free on
nebula the best way to support this
channel is by signing up to nebula
through the nebula and curiosity stream
bundle deal for just
14.79 a year that's just over one dollar
a month but that one dollar has a
gigantic impact on this channel because
we get to own and run our own streaming
platform and that gives us the freedom
to create what we want how we want a
little over one dollar a month this is
by far the best way to support this
channel and you get something in return
with access to both nebula and all the
amazing award-winning documentaries on
curiosity stream like this one called
hack the moon about the fascinating
technologies engineers developed for the
apollo moon missions you can sign up to
this amazing deal by clicking on this
button on screen right now or if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now you could watch our last video
on why building solar energy in the
sahara failed or you could watch real
science's latest video on why turtles
are perfectly evolved to be absolutely
screwed by human activity